comme je vous le disais on a mis en
place ludivine et fabien lecoeuvre
ludivine et fabien est ce que vous êtes
en place d'être sur l'autre plateau avec
le public est avec nous également là bas
regardez voilà ludivine fabien oui nous
regarder la caméra est la voie la
camerata fait son job pour les battez
vous va bien alors assis à ses côtés on
les entend pas alors c'est quoi je me
demande si je vais pas aller
ouais ouais ça sert à quoi de m cb
télétubbies ou quoi ça vient ça bien sûr
tout frais ludivine c'est très simple
fabien vous allez représenter le public
b c'est-à-dire le public de là bas et du
monde d'accord ludivine vous avez
représenté le public ici sachez que j'ai
envie de faire gagner un smartphone a
dit un des deux publics
[Applaudissements]
grâce à smart à gogo je peux faire
gagner un smartphone juste pour un
public je vous le dis je pourrais pas
faire gagner les deux parce que sinon
ils explosent la boîte à docs à l'arrêt
si ces radios l'auteur qui gagne c'est
le public de la balle publique beth qui
gagnera tous les smartphones et ben oui
si vous rentrerez gros jean comme devant
si c'est ludivine qui fait la meilleure
performance
c'est le public ici qui gagnera tous les
smartphones vous avez devant vous alors
c'est très simple vous avez devant vous
un tapis de glu oui oui d'accord
au bout de ce tapis il ya les
smartphones destinés à votre public
gagnant à mon top l'écran va commencer à
se baisser
vous avez deux minutes pour atteindre le
buzzer et bloqué la fermeture de l'écran
celui qui arrive le premier au bout du
parcours feuga pourra gagner des
smartphones grâce à smart à gogo pour la
partie du public qu'il représente
attention je pense qu'il faut que vous
preniez de l'élan là vous êtes trop près
il faut prendre plus dès lors les chiens
oui juste ne vous claquez pas d'accord
il faut courir à sinon vous allez si
vous vous y arriverez pas donner plus
d'élan prenez plus d'élan plus d'élan
reculer le maximum possible sinon vous y
arriverez pas j'ai essayé tout à l'heure
en répète c'est impossible sinon c'est
comme elle attrape mouches d'accord
exactement attention
3 abalo 3 2 1 au top
[Applaudissements]
du
son personnage ou patrick boyer fac
c'est de la merde et j'adore la
meilleure une question de raymond de
l'histoire mais ils n'ont pas essayé
avant je te rappelle que ça producteurs
de ces 8e frérot c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
et ferment ils ont dit on va boire ou
bah voilà donc merci donc c'est une
pièce la gagner c'est fait bien c'est
pas bien mais c'est pas bien c'est
fabien donc tout le public n'a pas
exposé
[Applaudissements]
pour me faire pardonner de ce pitoyable
happening merci cacoub et merci à
l'équipe geoff revient sur un smartphone
à tous
[Applaudissements]